retour en phase de rédaction pour la
suite du 19 20
anis naccache été affaiblis à l'hôpital
de la prison de fresnes
mais ce n'est pas par la grève de la
faim qu'il peut espérer se libérer vient
d'affirmer françois mitterrand un cargo
panaméen pro feuillère soir au large de
l'île d'ouessant les zones de membres
d'équipage ont été sauvés ramenée à
brest 1 me à gorbatchev est il vraiment
aux abois face à la situation intérieure
de l'urss ce matin la bourse de tokyo
semblez le croire
enfin 103 à 83 ans et de 20 points que
les basketteurs de limoges ont perdu
hier soir explique en yougoslavie en
coupe d'europe des champions
plus de peur que de mal au large de la
pointe de bretagne pour le cargo
panaméen qui avait pris feu la nuit
dernière l'intervention de la marine
nationale a permis de sauver les 22
membres d'équipage sept marins gardé en
observation le cargo qui transportait du
soja aurait pris feu à la suite de
l'explosion d'une conduite de fioul les
faits avec anne moreau 20h30 hier soir
une conduite de fioul explose dans la
salle des machines provoquant un
incendie un incendie qui se propage
immédiatement sur le connaît aussi à
bord 18 marins philippins et quatre
grecs
l'équipage se réfugie à l'avant du
bateau en attendant les secours
selon ce plan quelque chose a explosé
dans la salle des machines et nous avons
eu seulement une minute pour partir tout
stoppé par ailleurs impossible
d'éteindre le feu soit vous avez eu peur
n'ont pas peur parce que l'hélicoptère
et de nombreux bateaux sont arrivés nous
avons tout laissé wheel drive le film la
chance du cargo panaméen aura été sa
position dans une zone maritime très
fréquenté à 30 km seulement au large
d'ouessant
quelques minutes après avoir lancé un
sos un bâtiment de commerce est
allemands arrivent à la rescousse et
embarque 20 hommes les deux derniers
sont récupérés par un hélicoptère
ce soir sept marins sont encore en
traitement dans un caisson hyperbare à
l'hôpital durant la 110 il avait respiré
de l'oxydé de carbone en mer malgré les
efforts des quatre bâtiments de la
marine nationale le feu couve encore à
l'intérieur du cargo long 239 m remorqué
à l'extérieur du rail d'ouessant
le pioneer s'il restera au large
jusqu'à ce que tous dont g soit
définitivement écarté anis naccache ne
peut pas espérer se libérer par une
grève de la faim
et s'il décide de mourir en prison ce
sera sous sa responsabilité
c'est françois mitterrand qui
s'exprimait ainsi tout à l'heure à
l'elysée tout en redisant que nakache
peut toujours espérer être libéré un
jour après quatre mois de grève de la
faim nakache a perdu 26 kg l'iran a mis
en garde la france sur les conséquences
néfastes que pourrait engendrer sa mort
ce que représente aujourd'hui ce détenu
réponse avec joël hasard depuis quatre
mois anis naccache a fixé une
alternative à son destin la liberté ou
la mort
à l'origine sa grève de la faim entamée
la prison cerveau avait pour but de
rassembler dans le sens de les tensions
sont commando pour nakache le
regroupement des combattants de l'islam
arrêté avec lui lors de la tentative
d'assassinât de chapour bakhtiar un
moyen de pression sur le nouveau régime
iranien
il se rappelait ainsi au bon souvenir de
rafsanjani car le nouveau maître de
l'iran étaient bien déterminés à calmer
les ardeurs révolutionnaires
il a commencé l'été dernier à évincer
l'étonnant du radicalisme islamique
c'était compter sans les mener
souterrain de ses opposants l'ancien
ministre de l'intérieur moutacher mines
l'un des principaux acteurs dans la
sphère des otages occidentaux liban a
relancé les pressions pour la libération
d'un et cela cache
les autorités iraniennes lasserre
nakache constitue donc à nouveau depuis
deux mois une affaire d'état menace
d'attentât filière libanaise
reconstituer les compagnons nakache
mobilisent au fur à mesure que son état
empire et il ya quinze jours
l'ambassadeur d'iran à paris à du rapliq
la libération l'acteur faisait partie
des engagements de paris
une négociation sur les otages français
anis naccache ne peut espérer se libérer
par une grève de la faim disais tout à
l'heure françois mitterrand en europe de
l'est c'est à présent jusqu'à moscou que
se tournent les regards les soucis
intérieur de monsieur gorbatchev sont
multiples et les plus pessimistes
imagine déjà le numéro un soviétique aux
abois changement de calendrier en
dernière minute
annulation de rencontres à l'étranger et
climat de panique cet après midi à la
bourse de tokyo jean paul girouard quand
l'union soviétique s'enrhume les grandes
places financières tous début de panique
ce matin à la bourse de tokyo l'indicé
nikkei a plongé de 438 points un peu
plus de 1% du jamais vu depuis
l'affaissement du 16 octobre dernier
ardent supporter de la pérestroïka les
boursier nippon se sont inquiétés des
rumeurs selon lesquelles michael
gorbatchev aurait annulé tous ses rendez
vous pris ce mois ci avec des hommes
politiques étrangers
le leader travailliste neil kinnock il
devait rencontrer le maître du kremlin
le 16 janvier prochain rendez vous
reporté
confirmation à moscou c'est exact fait
nous avons beaucoup de problèmes en ce
moment il nécessite toute l'attention de
mikhaël gorbatchev
de fait le numéro un soviétique doit
s'attaquer à bras le corps aux problèmes
d'agitation nationaliste en premier lieu
l'azerbaïdjan depuis une semaine des
centaines de milliers de manifestants et
réclament l'abolition de la frontière
avec l'iran
les dates série soviétique veulent être
réuni avec les aguerris iranien dans un
grand à djerba jo aujourd'hui un début
de dialogue semble y avoir ramené le
calme
tout sera réglé comme le désirent les
azzuri a affirmé un envoyé spécial de
moscou y avoir gorbatchev devrait
préciser ses intentions face aux
problèmes et nationalité lors d'un
voyage en lituanie
la semaine prochaine en bref les autres
nouvelles de l'étranger est encore
l'europe de l'est lors ensuite mr
la ville de coeur djallit au sud de la
bulgarie complètement paralysée
aujourd'hui les nationalistes avaient
appelé à la grève générale pour
protester contre la nouvelle politique à
l'égard de la minorité turque
le nouveau régime a en effet accordé le
29 décembre dernier l'égalité des droits
ainsi que le rétablissement des noms et
de la religion de cette minorité
musulmane
nouvelle tentative de paix entre l'iran
et l'irak le président irakien saddam
hussein vient de proposer à l'iran un
plan en trois points qui prévoit
l'ouverture d'un dialogue direct sous
l'égide de l'onu les changes immédiat de
tous les prisonniers de guerre malades
ou invalides ainsi que l'ouverture des
frontières pour permettre les pèlerinage
sur les lieux saints des deux pays
au pakistan le bilan de la catastrophe
ferroviaire de sangin ne cesse de
s'alourdir plus de 350 morts ont d'ores
et déjà été découverts dans la carcasse
du train
le premier ministre pakistanais benazir
buttho n'a pas exclu qu'un acte de
sabotage soit à l'origine de l'accident
manuel antonio noriega vient d'être con
s'il peut être considéré comme un
prisonnier politique l'ancien homme fort
du panama qui a été officiellement
inculpé de complicité de trafic de
drogue ne reconnaît pas la compétence du
tribunal américain devant lequel il
comparaît il restera néanmoins en
détention préventive jusqu'à son procès
prévu dans un délai de neuf mois
demain soir 69 enfants roumains
atterriront à orly leurs parents
adoptifs français seront partis les
chercher le matin même à bord d'un avion
spécialement affrété par le quai d'orsay
pour cet aller retour que les familles
françaises attendaient depuis plus de
deux ans cérémonie de voeux à répétition
aujourd'hui pour françois mitterrand le
président de la république a reçu les
représentants de l'assemblée nationale
et des forces vives de la nation
c'est-à-dire les syndicats et les
associations entre autres compte rendu
avec eric piolle cent fois sur le métier
remettez votre ouvrage des progrès ont
certes été accomplis en matière
économique et social lors de l'année 89
près de 4 points de croissance 350 mille
emplois créés mais pour françois
mitterrand en est encore loin du compte
aussi le président de la république at
il invité les responsables syndicaux à
ne pas céder à la force de l'habitude
puis la responsabilité qui est la nôtre
autres la gaine 7 crs en boucle à l'un
des vieux métiers je crois qu'ils
pratiquaient dans nos villages ont si sa
reprise et a reprise et tous les jours
le travail entrepris la veille
j'ai toujours un fils qui part reprise
et le corps social de la nation en
essayant de venir à bout de cette
maladie si dramatique que constitue le
chômage et venir en aide à ceux qui
souffrent le plus des inégalités telles
sont les voeux formulés par françois
mitterrand pour l'année 90
jacques chirac de son côté aime rappeler
je crois ce que disait sa grand mère
dans la vie il faut reprise et les bas
et puis maîtriser les eaux comme un
implant sur la sur le crâne d'un chauve
et bien l'actualité va parfois plongé
très loin ses racines ainsi le reportage
que sylvie bosc heroes vient de nous
faire parvenir de lyon on y voit en
effet l'histoire de cinq avocats parti
en guerre contre les journaux gratuits
qui nous envahissent chaque jour ils ont
très sérieusement saisi le tribunal de
grande instance de lyon
regardez le reportage vous avez le temps
de la finance
c'est un journal qui demandent bien qu'à
cela ne tienne la société ncm
communication qui détient le ton de la
finance et business bourse deux journaux
financiers semblent concevoir la presse
comme une oeuvre philanthropique
si l'électeur ne viennent pas au journal
le journal tel le lagardère de base va a
eu un cabinet d'avocats lyonnais se
trouve ainsi inondé chaque matin depuis
quatre mois de ses exemplaires pour
lesquels ils n'ont jamais pris
d'abonnement et qu'ils ne veulent pas
lire nous avons refusé de nous abonner
et nous avons pu se replie de recevoir
ces exemplaires nous avons fait une
lettre recommandée de mise en demeure de
faire cesser ces expéditions et four
réponse nous avons reçu une lettre nous
informant le 14 décembre 1989 que le
temps de la finance mettrait lui en 1990
les bouchées doubles ces terres nous
recevrions chaque jour 32 exemplaires ou
de 16
nous avons reçu ensuite le 20 décembre
une lettre l'informant que nous étions
désormais membre fondateur et
que et paname occasion nous avons reçu
30 exemplaires
face au risque d'explosion de leur boîte
aux lettres et à l'obstination des deux
titres les avocats lyonnais ont les
nerfs qui lâchent
c'est le juge des référés désormais
chargé de la sphère qui devra convaincre
l'éditeur de cesser ce harcèlement
postale à moins qu en guise d'excusé les
avocates le voit offrir un abonnement à
vie à tant d'autres informations à
retenir en france des images qui nous
parviennent vous savez des 25 stations
régionales de la 3 commentaires ce soir
de sophie guillet
nouvelle alerte à la pollution à lyon
depuis ce matin le taux de dioxyde de
soufre dans l'atmosphère à cette fois
encore dépassé le seuil toléré
un arrêté préfectoral a été pris pour
obliger les 18 entreprises les plus
polluantes de la ville a utilisé un fuel
moins toxique jusqu'à ce que la
situation revienne à la normale
un geyser de kérosène voilà ce qu'on a
pu voir ce matin rémy en moselle
c'est un coup de pelleteuse malheureux
qui est à l'origine de l'accident
par chance le lait au duc touché n'était
pas en service à ce moment là ce qui a
limité les dégâts mais le propriétaire
du terrain va devoir s'expliquer il a en
effet fait effectuer des travaux de
terrassement sans prendre toutes les
précautions nécessaires ni avertir la
municipalité bonne nouvelle pour les
conchyliculteurs de l'étang de thau
l'aide promise par l'état leur sera
versée très rapidement c'est ce qu'a
confirmé le chef du cabinet du ministre
de la mer qui rencontrait aujourd'hui
des élus locaux et des représentants de
la profession
dès lundi des formulaires
d'indemnisation seront disponibles et
les versements pourrez commenter dans
une semaine
un mot de sport il hier soir à split en
yougoslavie
les basketteurs limougeauds sont
véritablement retombé sur terre ils ont
concédé 20 points au champion d'europe
en titre
malgré cette défaite le csp limoges
garde toutes ses chances de disputer les
demi finales limoges recevra d'ailleurs
jeudi prochain les grecs de l'aris de
salonique jean-philippe bien fin de
match catastrophique de limoges dans la
salle des champions d'europe les
yougoslaves de ce pli jusque là bien
muselé par les français en profite pour
faire passer le compteur à +20 en leur
faveur les contre attaques assassines se
succèdent limoges explose devant la
classe et la complémentarité de yugo
plastique à
on a craqué en début de deuxième
mi-temps dû aussi à une préparation très
perturbée puisque pendant 20 jours on
n'a pas fait de match dur l'a pas fait
de match difficile alors que split
étaient au tournoi de madrid ont fait
ont livré trois matches durs alors c'est
certain qu'ils ont des ennemis tant les
joueurs ont craqué parce qu'on va perdre
et des automatismes on perdait la
condition physique
et pourtant les verts emmenés par de
maury et dacoury sont à créditer d'une
superbe première mi temps mais les
remplaçants yougoslave hôtelière de 32
points sont bien supérieurs au ban de
limoges score final 103 83 20 points
représentatif de la domination du go
slave la série de 29 victoires
consécutives pour les verts est terminée
suite emmené par irrésistible tonique ou
coach à la technique parfaite fait
figure de grand favori pour le titre de
champion champion d'europe des clubs
ce soir sur la chaîne superbe soirée
20h35 la mer monte comme tous les
vendredis thalassa talent et ça nous
emmènera dans l'archipel des
nouvelles-hébrides aujourd'hui le van
uhm as-tu 22h30 votre prochain rendez
vous avec l'information soir 3 sera
présentée par maguy gilbert 22h55 la
soirée comme une antenne 2 fr3 deux
heures de direct pour fêter les 15 ans
d'existence des deux chaînes du service
public
quinze ans de fiançailles puis
maintenant nous sommes mariés nous avons
un président voilà cette édition du 19
20 se termine merci de l'avoir suivi à
tout de suite la météo complète de
michel touré adama laurence excellente
soirée à demain voir
m